so what I wanted to do here is make a
video designed to answer the question
what do I need to know to start reading
DC Comics right now and so the first
step to answering our question comes in
the form of DC's continuity and the
various problems that they've had over
the course of their publication history
and taking a trip back in time when DC
entries Superman in 1938 they
established what we call the Golden Age
of comics and because Superman was so
revolutionary his success came with the
introduction of Batman Wonder Woman
Aquaman the flash Jay Garrick and the
Green Lantern Allen Scott while there
were other creations during this time
these individuals represented the core
of DC's lineup now having said that when
the popularity of superheroes began to
drop off in the early 1950s the Green
Lantern and the flash series were
cancelled but when superheroes became
popular again a couple years later in
the mid-1950s
DC decided to reinstate them however
since Jay Garrick the original flash and
Allen Scott the original Green Lantern
were unable to maintain their own sales
DC decided to replace them with Barry
Allen Hal Jordan and so when those
comics were released and started the
Silver Age fans became confused and the
reason why was because if Superman
Batman Wonder Woman and Aquaman all
still had the same identities then why
did the identities of flash and Green
Lantern change to answer this question
DC created the multiverse and what they
said was that all the stories involving
they're coming Republicans from the
introduction of Superman in 1938 up to
the introduction of Barry Allen in 1956
took place in an alternate reality
called earth to all the stories after
the introduction of Barry Allen took
place in a reality called earth one now
while this allowed DC to explain away
things like why Superman in the 1950s
was far more powerful than his version
in the 1940s it also created a problem
with the idea of alternate realities on
the table DC now had the ability to
create a litany of stories featuring
alternate versions of their characters
before example and world's finest volume
1 issue number 172 in 1967 DC introduced
an alternate reality that centered on a
world where Bruce Wayne was adopted by
the Kent's and became the brother of
Superman an adventure comics volume 1
issue number 387 and 1969 DC introduced
an alternate reality where everyone in
the world
werewolves well it was cool to see
alternate versions of DC's top
characters the problem was that after a
while so many alternate realities
existed that it was impossible for a new
reader to make heads or tails of what
was considered in continuity and what
wasn't and so in 1985 DC launched the
crisis on Infinite Earths wipe the slate
clean and started over however because
the idea of alternate realities
continued to exist by 2011 DC was in the
exact same problem they had a ton of
alternate realities they had crossovers
between those alternate realities and
new readers didn't know where to start
and so like 1985 they introduced the new
52 event which wiped the slate clean and
removed all of the alternate realities
and past continuities for their
characters except for Batman and Green
Lantern now the reason why these two
didn't see their histories wipe clean
was because they were the highest
selling comics DC had at the time and it
didn't make any sense to put that in
jeopardy for the sake of a line wide
reboot instead with Batman they just
said that all of his stories between
crisis on Infinite Earths in 1985 up to
the new 52 happened over the course of
five years and with the Green Lantern
they simply said that all his history
had happened but they didn't convince it
down to a five year window now following
the new 52 and the establishment of this
new continuity referred to as earth zero
in 2015 DC launched convergence now the
official story was that DC was moving
offices and simply needed content to
produce but I would argue that DC was
looking at past issues involving access
to their comics for new readers and was
experimenting with the idea of removing
continuity and taking a stab at
introducing story-driven comics but
regardless of the reason in addition to
a series of two issues stories featuring
realities from DC's entire publication
history prior to the new 52 reboot
convergence had a main story and while
I'll have a video out in the next few
days explaining the entire plot and what
it entails the conclusion of convergence
saw DC undoing the crisis on Infinite
Earths
in 1985 what this meant was that because
the crisis on Infinite Earths was
originally designed to eliminate all of
the continuity prior to 1985 with crisis
on it but it's now being treated as if
it never happened all realities and
versions of characters that have ever
existed since the introduction of
Superman in 1938 were back on the table
in addition to this DC dropped the new
52 branding kept the origin stories and
cotton new
for the new 52 versions of characters
and said that it's now one of the many
continuities that exists as part of
their multiverse furthermore post
convergence DC launched the DCU line and
when they did they canceled the titles
that weren't selling handed mediocre
titles over to new creative teams and
kept the same writers and artists on
titles at worst selling now with regards
to continuity DCU establishes that
stories written as part of DC you are
basically self-contained meaning readers
can pick up Justice League issues three
four five and six then skip to issue
number forty with the start of Darkseid
war and find Superman in his blue
uniform and red cape but in Action
Comics and Superman's solo stories they
find him almost powerless with the
Superman truth event now it may be that
DC will read Caan all of these stories
together and tell us when Darkseid war
takes place in reference to Batman
endgame and Superman truth but at the
moment the emphasis seems to be more on
stories rather than continuity and so
that being said we're gonna bring this
video to an end I hope this all made
sense so any questions you guys have in
case I didn't explain things clearly
enough I'll try to answer down in the
comment section and I will catch you
guys later peace